Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Arrow dropped
a whole bunch of teasers for the 100th episode
and you can see what they're doing is it a
Black Canary green Arrow wedding from the
comics so i'll also explain that storyline because
it's not exactly what arrow's doing but that's
kind of the joke they're going for with this.
So for all of you collectively mouthing WTF
is going on the 100th episode is supposed
to be a parallel reality where Oliver wakes
up to a world where he never got on the Queen's
gambit.
That's why you see Sara in these photos because
she got on the Queen's gambit with him.
Robert Queen is here and because Ray is here
I think this is meant to be in present day
in this alternate reality but here's the synopsis
so I'll just read this.
It doesn't give away too much but it gives
you kind of an idea, it says Arrow celebrates
100 episodes the epic superhero crossover
continues because this is the third night
of the four night crossover Oliver wakes up
to a life where he never got on the Queen's
gambit Robert and Moira Queen are alive and
well Laurel is his loving fiancée and their
wedding is imminent.
Everything seems perfect but Oliver starts
to notice imperfections that make him question
this new reality.
Meanwhile Felicity and the recruits take on
a new threat with the help of the flash and
Supergirl.
So what it sounds like is happening.
You know Batman Perchance to Dream style.
You have Oliver in this fake reality at the
mercy of the Dominators while the rest of
the team in real time like in the real world
are trying to defeat the dominators.
So as you would expect he starts to realize
that the reality that he's in isn't real he
comes out and we've seen like a couple clips from
the four night crossover were he's firing
dominator weapons like on one of their ships.
So maybe he's in like one of these pods or
something like that wakes up and just starts going
crazy on everyone and everything goes back
to normal with them trying to get them off
the planet but for the most part when they
said they tried to represent every big character
that had ever been on Arrow in the hundredth
episode, most of that seems like it's gonna
take place in this dream land where Oliver
is getting ready to get married to Laurel
for the most part there are a couple big things
that are missing in these pictures that we
don't know about. Merlyn would be there he's
probably in the episode somewhere but he
had already gone to join the league of assassins
independently of Oliver and Robert and Sara
getting on the Queen's gambit so whenever
we see Merlyn they'll have to address what's
going on with the undertaking because Moira
was tied up in all that in season one independently
of what was going on with Robert but speaking
of Merlyn the other big thing now Tommy is
still alive because he died when Oliver went
to war with Merlyn he died because of all
the undertaking craziness.
So if the Dominators are re-creating Oliver's
life and in like presenting him with like
a really saccharine version of what it might've
been like I'm wondering if the undertaking
is still going to happen.
But I'm assuming.
Not because Oliver probably realizes that
like some of the people he runs into in this
dream land are either dead or super evil.
So it'll be funny to see like the clues that
he starts to recognize that let him know that
this is not the reality that he supposed to
be in the other thing about this too is like
you see the idea of Oliver getting married
to Laurel and you think about Black Canary
getting married to Green Arrow in the comics
this isn't necessarily that, because Oliver
would not have become the Green Arrow had
he not gotten on the Queen's gambit so there's no
green Arrow Sara would not have joined the
league of assassins had she not got on.
So there's no original Black Canary to inspire
Laurel to become the Black Canary herself.
So in this reality here you're minus like
a couple really big superheroes.
So this isn't necessarily a comic book-y thing
But just to explain that storyline though what
happened is is the green Arrow had his own
solo series at the end of that run he proposed
to Black Canary.
So this wedding special issue was like the
beginning of their ongoing series together
green Arrow and Black Canary that was like
an ongoing series but the big twist is is
that the Amazons had replaced Oliver with
Everyman a shape changer because after their
wedding wedding night you know great the gonna
go have sex is gonna be awesome but he starts
to go crazy and attacks her and she's like
Ollie why you attacking us on our wedding night
so you learn that it was really Everyman.
It was an imposter and that big WTF moment
led into their ongoing series so the funny
thing is is like you know, this Arrow wedding
is meant to be fake it's like happening in Oliver's
head but in the comics it was kind of fake
too so that's the big twist but you guys can let me know
what you think about all this.
You can see how they've kind of like shoehorned
in some of the other characters to this dream
land like if Oliver were experiencing this
like super sweet dream land that was meant
to trap him he probably wouldn't be dreaming
of Ray Palmer but because it's during the big
four night crossover you have to have like
all the characters in there somewhere.
so have like the dreamland then you have the
stuff happening in real life so I'm not expecting
Oliver to spend the entire episode in this
false reality you know maybe most of the episode maybe
like half of it, you guys can let me know
in the comments what do you think is the final
thing that tips Oliver off that this is all
fake the going from like one end of the crazy spectrum
to the complete opposite.
So I'm not a super big fan of weddings on
Arrow.
But I think the rest of the episode will be
a lot of fun.
I mean it is fun to see Laurel back.
But if we're going to get Laurel back I would
rather her be like metahuman Black Canary
but none of this answers the question as to
how Laurel's coming back in the back half of
the season so like she's supposed to show
up during episode 10, but we don't know how
that's can happen and that's also supposed
to coincide with Talia Al Ghul coming on
the TV show so even though we're seeing a bunch
of crazy hundredth episode stuff that says
nothing about what's going to be happening
in the back half of the season so because
Arrow is on break next week what they might
do it just release more footage of this,
so this episode of Arrow like the big four
night crossover isn't happening for two weeks.
Next week there's only Supergirl and flash.
Everything else is on break.
So I'll remind everyone what's going on when
I post my flash video next week but there
is a new round of the DC giveaway it's a $20
Amazon gift card.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so what
I'm going to do next is post a Deadpool video
Ryan Reynolds said a whole bunch of funny
stuff in an interview about the original Deadpool
character that he did during Wolverine Origins
about the Deadpool movie and the Deadpool
Sequel so whole bunch of Deadpool coming in
a little while while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for the trailer
for the big 4 night crossover and you click here
for the trailer for the next episode of the
flash the Killer Frost episode thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!